Hey everyone.  We're going to take a look at why good divisions make bad decisions.
And to do this, we're going to look at profit and cost centers, incentive misalignment and organizational solutions through our example firm, Next Tech.
Let's dive into it.
At NexTech, every division is sharp and focused on delivering results.
The battery division is very efficient and very profitable.
The the devices division is also known for its award winning designs and rapid time to market.
Each division is excelling in its own right and yet the company's losing ground.
This creates kind of a paradox for us.
How can each division be profitable but the company losing ground?
Well, it started when the battery division started charging near market prices to internal buyers.
and this includes its sister division, the device division.
While the better division's margins soared, the device division faced higher input costs.
And so they cut production to preserve their bottom line.  What was the result?
Company wide profit decline.
This is a textbook case of incentive misalignment.
Both divisions are profit centers, meaning they optimize for their own profit and loss even when that harms total firm value.
More formally, we can say it's part of a business that's responsible for generating revenues and costs such as retail or product lines.
Instead, one division should have been acting as a cost center, a part of business that incurs costs but does not directly generate revenue, such as HR or it.
So let's apply a simple framework.
Three questions to diagnose misaligned incentives.
The first question, who made the bad decision in this case the battery division by charging too much internally?
Second question, did they have the right information?
Yes.  They knew devices were struggling.
Third question, were incentives aligned with NexTech?
No.  They were paid for their own profit, not the firm's.
This is a version of the principal agent problem.
In NexTech's case, however, the agents are not individuals but but entire units or divisions.
Here these divisions act as rational economic agents, optimizing their own performance metrics, often at the expense of the overall firm value.
When divisions are evaluated solely on their profit and loss statements, they may make perfectly logical decisions within their own boundaries, such as maximizing internal transfer prices.
But these local optimizations can generate negative externalities for other divisions and reduce the system wide efficiency.
So our root problem here is not that it's divisional, it's structural.
It's not about the bad actors inside the divisions.  They're not bad.
It's about the design of the unintentionally that unintentionally encourages suboptimal behavior.
The firm's Architecture rewards siloed success, but fails to internalize the broader consequence of and that's a condition, when left unresolved, systematically erodes long term competitiveness and value creation.
So let's take this a step further.
The consequences of misaligned incentives go far beyond missed revenue.
Product launches were delayed as the device division struggled to beat cost targets.
Cross functional collaboration grounded to a halt.
Here the engineers stopped talking to procurement marketing loss visibility in the timelines and, and then we had.
Instead of solving customer problems, division heads had to spend their time lobbying to the headquarters, fighting for better internal deals and transfer terms.
What should have been a streamlined, high performing organization became a collection of disconnected internal factions.
So what we see here, these aren't isolated inefficiencies.
It's just a classic symptom of coordination failure.
From an organizational economics perspective, what we see here are two critical costs.
Our first is coordination costs.
These arise when different parts of the organization fail to align their actions or synchronize their decision making.
Poorly integrated systems, conflicting incentives and unclear roles create bottlenecks that delay innovation and increase error rates.
Our second is attention misallocation.
This is a term borrowed from behavioral and strategy literature.
And this refers to how organizational actors focus their energy on internal battles such as budget negotiations.
Blame shifting political maneuvering rather than on the external threats, market opportunities or customer needs.
In system terms, NexTech's divisions are maximizing local objectives at the expense of the global coherence.
Again, this is the paradox that exists whenever we have these misaligned incentives amongst the organization's divisions.
So here, when internal negotiations dominate the agenda, firm loses the agility and dilutes its strategic intent, which slowly erodes its competitive advantage.
Ultimately, what we see is the company stops responding to the market and and starts reacting to itself.